hey Brian this is Dan Shapiro from the
Harvard international negotiation
program your question is what's the most
interesting idea you've heard today it's
it's somewhat of an idea it was a good
am it was a session on values and the
main topic that we were discussing was
about the disconnect between the values
that people a spouse and what they
actually do and I think this is a really
important thing for our global community
thinking about whether it is a Wall
Street espousing certain values and then
living different values whether it's
families the husbands wives get into a
fight and yesterday espoused love and
connection and family and then the
moment they get into a fight all those
values fall apart so I think it's a
really important thing for our global
community at all levels a personal
organizational level and the global
leadership level is to take a good hard
look at how do we deal with this
disconnect between what we say our
values and what we actually do so thanks
so much